mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir raymond bonsoir françois copé
est tout un prêt pour nous présenter une
recette ce soir quand vous aviez l'air
très cher si vite fait et oui j'étais
très des bovidés paisible ici comprendre
alors voilà je vais mettre voyez-vous
dans ses petites rues alors ce petit
truc là c'est une pâte ne pas te fait
avec des biscuits d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure nous aurons à voir en détail qui
comme ça tout bête tout bête tu discutes
ouvert alors avec le doigt comme ceci je
vais repartir cette pâte qui est sèche
joyau qui se présente face à ces
glorieux lui avait fait subir tout un
doublé je vous allez voir ailleurs je
vais le faire bien sûr là je la fais
parce que rapidement pour que le premier
la première tarte soit cuite lorsque
nous aurons fini l'émission inflation à
pouvoir la montrer tous les patriotes
vie n'est pas tricher je ne veux jamais
triché on va être mis à cuire à la fin
de l'émission avec lui ce seuil soit le
temps est énorme à fait normal
absolument normal il s'agit d'un quart
d'heure de cuisson et puis cinq minutes
de repos et puis à nouveau de quelques
minutes de cuisson alors oui à deux
sections succès si oui mais alors là
j'en parlerai je ne sais pas si ce site
nécessaire que ça de faire cette seconde
cuisson personnellement je le crois pas
mais j'ai voulu être entendu et régulier
vous allez nous dire dans quelques
instants où vous avez que la nécessaire
de révéler qu'il faut garder du suspect
pour l'instant dans la salle est même
d'être assez difficiles à manipuler non
pas du tout au contraire et au c'est une
pâte qui est relativement sèche
ça me fait penser on se croirait à la
fin je fais ça oui ça ressemble beaucoup
à du sable et ses fragiles pas ça fait
rêver c'est le jeu sera bleu
voilà alors où j'avais partie
convenablement cette femme qui est une
foudre plus ou moins souples d'ailleurs
et il convient de saluer au passage il y
as emmènera tout allait oui il y a des
biscuits inde et puisque tout bête et du
200 g de petits beurre c'est ça et puis
100 g de beurre fondu une cuillère à
soupe de sucre en poudre et une pincée
de sel moi je gagne assez difficile ici
voilà voilà la préparation est ce qu est
l utiliser ce que l'on aimerait
d'ailleurs immédiatement avec la
répartir et l'affairé cuire 2 face à ce
que je veux comme je vous ai dit ça soit
trouvée car nous aurons fini mais en
fait c'est bizarre alors qu'est ce
qu'ils en souffrent marc sait bien où
irait bien au moyenâgeux vous savez 4 et
il n'y avait pas de pâtisseries au
beurre la plupart les pâtisseries
étaient au fromage comme la brioche
entre parenthèses cela nous avons la
consonance d'ailleurs nous le dit
brit-brit le fromage de briques et au
chai qui voulait dire remuez remuer
comme le rocher des enfants n'est ce pas
quelque chose que l'on remue alors ça
voyez vous je vais là voilà elle est
toute prête et je vais la mettre à cuire
au four et puis ta leur camp alors non
moyen
moyen je le règle aurait probablement en
cours de cuisson pour le moment
réchauffer une façon à peu près régulier
jeudi à peu près rien et si vous avez le
temps combien de temps maintenant nous
reste-t-il vous avez mis il faudra un
bon quart d'heure de cuisson pour la
tarte voilà vous avez mis 3 3 minutes la
santé bien maintenant nous pourrions
voir catherine si vous le voulez comment
ai je fait pour glaner cette pièce c'est
vraiment a été de l'année cette recette
bien loin et va nous faire en amérique
et nous allons regarder un petit film
qu'il a tourné lui-même je crois bien
vous fait tourner au nom
je dirais oui et alors nous allons
regarder vous allez vous expliquer car
vous êtes là en compagnie d'une
charmante jeune femme oui mais ça se
passe à paris vous savez catherine
ashton amérique je sais bien m'a fait
les
regardons à la haine le pays et les rues
de la paix est le fait du lèche vitrine
lui lâché carreau le film a l'air d'être
un petit peu en veine amateurs savent et
voilà alors voila voila ma cuisine alors
à ce moment alors allez vous êtes avec
la fée du logis française car en fait
cette mi 6 america ne s'agit pas d'une
miss mais d'une mi6 américain et la fée
du logis amérique alors elle va
m'expliquer la recette elle va la faire
pour moi à 90 % puisque la cuisson un
seul sera mon fait et puis elles valent
à déguster avec moi pour bien voir si je
ne me suis pas trompé vous êtes le la
faction je suis le fait de logis mal
envoyé où elle était très ennuyeux très
ennuyé pour fabriquer ses recettes parce
qu'elle n'avait pas les petites mesures
américaines car les mains des américains
ont des tasses et des cuillères et tout
ça est universel c'est fait à peu près
sur la même
grandeur dans toute l'amérique
alors voyez c'est tout à fait simple la
façon dont elle travaille elle procédait
qu'en japonais les sûretés serge armand
est une vraie oui alors c'est la fameuse
dame pasteur
mormons à un passe-temps moment je
pensais que les mormons était polygame
ligue 1 je lui ai demandé s'il en est
est ainsi maintenant il paraît que non
ils sont revenus me et d'une bonne
taille et d'une bonne taille réduite
mans avec les les talons aiguilles et la
coiffure un peu élevé l'était plus
grande que moi mais regardez la fée du
logis française qui est une charmante
jeune femme du nord je crois que l'est
de l'île de roubaix ou de tourcoing et
cette envie de gagner dès qu'elles
avaient des enfants aussi elle en a un
en préparation ça se voit un peu
d'ailleurs à fait dit le jour le 16 mai
oui mais la finale à quatre ou cinq
qu'elle espère en avoir au moins autant
dans les dents les flûtes et l'enfant
dans les quelques mois qui suivent enfin
tout à l'heure il y avait six enfants
non à la fois que la nacelle
seulement
en tout cas ça lui réussit fort bien et
elle a l'air de très bien faire la
cuisine pour les pour les américains et
cette recette de tarte au fromage vous
ne la renie et pas or pas du tout moi
même vous savez dans les films
américains j'aime pas ça bc je crois que
c'est en fait la tarte à la crème reste
le le le comment dirais-je le gant les
motifs des films comiques ça n'a jamais
je n'ai jamais trompé personne c'est
joli tas d'excusés mad être ajoutée est
la vôtre sera aussi belle tout cas je
l'espère je l'espère d'ailleurs tenu
pendant que vous allez regarder ça de
seconde je vais aller voir mais là je
vois je vois ça très bien ça va très
bien nous ça se passe très bien alors
maintenant je vais tout de même vous
parlez de la recette et puis je m'en
vais l'exécuter pour vous avec les
différents moyens et les moyens là elle
fait le glaçage ce gars sages dont nous
allons parler le plus fort ont
d'ailleurs je vais le faire également
mais je n'y crois pas je ne crois pas
cette partie de la recette qui ne me
paraît pas fini ni très utile eu ni sera
grande quand on n'aime pas quand ni
jolie n'est ni bonne enfin je crois que
on se tient beaucoup à certains critères
qui ne sont pas absolument nécessaires
d'ailleurs vous êtes en train de faire
du charme auprès de 7 comment s'appelle
hausse alors il s'appelle miss mi6 à
merci sapers america vous allez nous
dire si ce plafond le mangeant pour
commencer non non ça c'est celle d'un
dessert c'est un dessert ou alors ou
alors ce qui est encore beaucoup plus
utile peut-être c'est le prototype du
gâteau de tickets que l'on manque que
l'on mange pour le thé que l'on mange
après midi un goûter alors effectivement
il a le côté fromages oui j'ai apprécié
d'ailleurs je veux vous dire quelque
chose c'est que cette tarte au fromage
qui est d'origine française et ceci est
absolument indiscutable et qui a
complètement disparu de nos tables de
plus 2 302 ou 300 ans et bien c'est un
des plats que je préfère en amérique
c'est un de ses trois ou quatre plans
américains et qui sont excellents et
d'ailleurs dans cette fameuse
controverse qui existe actuellement
entre le chef de la maison blanche et
qui a déserté la maison blanche et puis
des nouvelles halles à paris mais très
et puis mon ami 1 et mes amis qui
avaient lequel ils se sont heurtés eh
bien il dit lui que le chef de la maison
blanche de français dit qu'une meilleure
recette qui nous reste en amérique il
reste un mec c'est cet art from
ajustements bon alors voilà pour
commencer nous allons prendre des
biscuits et des petits beurres que nous
allons royaux légèrement concassé comme
ceci vous fait voir qu'à plusieurs
méthodes pour cela elle a toujours il
faut d'abord les immigrés le bridge est
comme ça oui qu'elles ont alors allez
passer dans le mixeur alors ça c'est une
aide américaine savez là la jeune femme
lorsqu'elle a voulu faire sa recette
elle a commencé par regarder la marque
du mixeur koenigsegg qui avait accepté
rat est bien le maillot vous savez je
crois qu'avec smic cela nous ne pourrons
pas faire votre la recette du duo pas
pourquoi elle me dit parce que le mien
il à six vitesses zf et voir qui s'il y
en avait huit
ans
comme c'est reparti
papa et maman les usagers sur mon sport
bon
ça m'a peut être rien
il est temps
non
voilà où l'est pas j'ai fait une toute
petite erreur et technique comme
toujours
dans la mécanique je suis tout à fait
vais les prendre voila
voila clément
alors en quelques secondes
on va envoyer
voilà alors tout à l'heure je vous fais
voir comment on ne peut les broyer tout
simplement parce que je souhaite bien
que toutes nos téléspectatrices et des
jeux c'est bien mais si par hasard elle
n'avait pas tout de même qu'elle puisse
faire c'est ce que j'avais à dire et
cela va faire
pareil pourquoi vous lui ferez parce que
je suis paré seriez-vous j'ai que ça à
faire pour le démonter mais je ne me
suis toujours dit non ça me suffit c'est
là alors ici voyez-vous une
cuillère à soupe
une cuillère à soupe dessus non une
pincée de sel
ainsi 200 et 100 g de beurre fondu
à noter bien ça au passage nous vous
rappellerons tout à l'air sans gras 100
g de beurre
alors justement du juste juste fondu et
puis je vais mélanger tout ça et je vais
obtenir cette pâte que vous avez vu tout
à l'heure et dont je me suis servi pour
foncer le moule elle était beaucoup plus
des seychelles à elle va se faire
absorber un bon élève n'y a pas deux
comme le beurre le berre pendant
exclusivement oui le beurre est toujours
est absorbée mais ses centres et ses
traits on n'est pas du tout non non à
cet amusant voyous et cette pâte qui
fait d'ailleurs un tout petit peu
l'originalité de la recette est non
seulement l'originalité mais mon avis la
qualité de la recette car c'est très
très bon c'est très très bon en a laissé
friable c'est rester curieux alors
justement cette jeune américaine me
disais en main vous avez fait une tarte
qui se tient sur elle même la nôtre ne
se tient pas il faut absolument la
manger à la cuillère il faut la mettre
dans une assiette et et manger cela avec
une cuillère c'est très bon alors là
aussi je n'y crois pas beaucoup à cette
histoire
voyez vous ce n'est pas défendable quand
même non j'aime j'aime bien qu'on
mordent une tarte qu'on puisse m'en
dedans et demandant dans le système que
j'ai adopté n'est ce pas et bien
effectivement je crois que l'on peut
mordre dans la tarde d'ailleurs je vous
le ferez voir c'est très amusant alors
là maintenant il ya la notion du choix
du fromage quel fromage faut-il pas eh
bien nous avons en france a un côté de
l'amérique évidemment une grande
richesse de ce format un grand choix est
bien là aussi cette jeune femme avait
très peur parce que le fromage de huy
consignes ou dut ou de l'utah où je ne
sais quel état américain qui est celui
qu'il faut prendre alors elle croyait
qui ne ressemblait en rien en réalité
comme je vais assez souvent en amérique
qui j'ai l'habitude de manger du fromage
là bas je savais que nous avions des
fromages non seulement meilleur au point
de vue goût mais qui convenait
parfaitement au point de vue textures
alors je peux dire sans avoir aucun
risque de me tromper que tous ces
fromages à caractères blancs un tout
petit peu du style petit suisse mais un
peu plus ferme maillot c'est celui ci
que j'ai choisie qui est un tout petit
peu plus ferme que le jeu blanc à
fromage blanc ni non il peut être
légèrement salée puisque de toute façon
il va rentrer du sel dans cette recette
bon alors c'est celui là que j'ai choisi
il en faut si j'ai bonne mémoire 300
grands volets vous verrez c'est qu'on a
fait c'est ça 300 g alors les voilà je
les ai réparé en morceaux il est inhumé
à peine parce que alors là aussi il faut
qu'il soit à la température de la pièce
oui bien sûr ils n'ont pas intérêt à
être à sortir du réfrigérateur et d'être
très froid mais savait il se croit très
grave au bout d'un instant les indiens
alors ici la chaleur ambiante c'est un
rêve alors voyez vous je les jeux
commencent pas le ramollir comme ceci ce
que tout de même extrêmement saine dans
vraiment non vraiment pas tellement
alors là
tu l'envoies qui va tout de même
permettre de
ramener une recette des états unis qui
vous est vraiment séduit par cette date
rien n'a beaucoup de recettes qui m'ont
séduit aux états unis n'y a pas que
celle-là vous savez il y donne des
recettes en extrêmement amusante ils en
ont assez peu voilà la vérité et la
plupart du temps on s'aperçoit qu'elles
sont strictement elle son jugement en
amérique sans l'ensemble le truchement
de comme c'est pas moins de 2 des ruines
on panique même pas de cuisinier du viol
y ait des pionniers du canada comme
les autres autrement dit vous avez
retrouvé vos recettes et mais quand vous
avez eu à se donner deux jours près
catherine alors n'importe quel à
l'oreille vous là dedans on y va rentrer
du sucre pardon merci alors ya deux des
trois cuillères à soupe de sucre alors
si vous la voilà lundi je me passais le
sucre il est pas votre droit
je vais vous offrir ces deux confiseurs
tiens vous alors 3 qui est soupe de
sucre 2 3 la vanille aussi alors un
petit tube de vanille à rebours vous
aviez un petit
bien à propos de la vanille avec votre
collègue américain disputé à huy et
laver la vanille elle volait à vanier
incolore elle croyait que si la vanille
était de la vraie vanille et bien ça
pouvait pas marcher il fallait
absolument que pour respecter car alors
ils sont dix ans méticuleux cas
différente d'une recette alors ses tapas
croit on si on leur dit de gouttes de
jus de citron pour rien au monde ils en
mettront trois enfants étaient nés
voulzy alors la parole j'ai dit le jus
d'un demi citron sel à affoler mais elle
m'a dit monsieur des citoyens à toutes
les tailles et il faut une tasse de jus
de citron et non pas le jus d'un
demi-citron jeudi écouter le site ont
corrigé patron qu'a livrée
on a des gîtes ont ils sont tous pareils
ou à peu près il varie de qui en fait ça
changera quelque alors là encore une
fois extérieurement ils peuvent avoir un
aspect beaucoup plus haut que l'autre
alors pour vous d'être très épaisse et
puis à l'intérieur oui mais dans tout ça
c'est vrai tout çà c'est ah oui mais
c'est pas là c'est pas le citron qu'elle
contestait c'était là la quantité de
liquide par courriel à contester la
qualité de victime alors d'ailleurs ça a
été pour elle une très grande surprise
lorsqu'elle a goûté le
débat qu'elle était aussi bonne que
reste il ne me l'a pas dit mais c'est
vraiment très bon à la différence est
alors alors vraiment très étonné alors
absolument suffoquer que ça puisse être
bon alors là je crois que j'ai un fou et
qui est en votre droite alors là ce on
peut arriver très facilement à faire le
mélange sans ce point mais c'est plus de
pratique que voulait me fallait pas
procédé au fur et à mesure fallait pas
faire le mélange du sucre n'a pas su se
jeta alors comme j'ai tout fait dans des
vols courts et vs contradictions alors
voyez vous ici avec le fouet comment si
elle veut éviter ça l était synonyme en
catastrophe et elle me regarde avec un
air tout à fait
comment dirais-je ou très mais vraiment
et ce que l'on peut servir d'un outil
ans batteur novateur dans le genre de
celui ci veut y aller entendu comme
société aversa parce que bien entendu
ils n'entendent plus petit que celui-là
ou en satin comme il est tout neuf j'ai
peur de le casser au congrès mais c'est
tout
si je n'étais pas un peu trouillard sur
les bords
voilà alors là où la veille vous n'êtes
pas obligé d'avoir en mélange très
homogène et angers vous dire
effectivement oui il y en a beaucoup et
bien ce n'est pas grave étant donné que
le maire du loup une pâte levée la rf et
ça n'a plus aucune gravité dès que le
mélange et non pas du tout on ne
m'aurait pas trahi et 4 alors là il y a
des notions de finition du gâteau alors
je m'en vais leur faire si vous la peine
et non je veux laver ça
pendant ce temps là je vais dire qui a
gagné
oui qui a gagné cette semaine cette 15è
notre concours du jeu 1 2 harry magie
vous avez retenu mais oui comme une
grosse bernard qui vous envoie je
m'excuse de dire ça aux milliers mais
nous avons discuté cela tous les deux
nous avons vous avez tous à 7 n'en avait
partout 12 ou 15 j'en ai retenu une
parce que c'est jean tigana voyez vous
elle me donne beaucoup de travail cette
dame à lonato fois j'aurais dû la punit
a malgré malgré ses qualités j'avais dû
le finir et pour m'avoir fait donner aux
la barigoule est c'est délicieux repas
toutes ces choses absolument délicieux
alors madame rose bernard de la côte
d'or à tout prix à gagner le jeu de
harry magie de la cuisine voilà alors
nous voulons verrons bien sûr très vite
très vite après l'émission cela dit on
félicitant madame rose bernard et de son
gain nous revenons à notre recette nous
revenons à notre recette de tarte au
fromage alors là nous avons nous allons
la refaire maintenant tout
tranquillement nous avons dû tout
recommencer encore une fois je vais
recommencer une fois je comprends plus
si remarquer que si vous voulez non je
vais pas le faire tenez nous allons
simplement faire une finition possible
et localement également pour vente entre
eux non mais ça ça va très bien voilà ça
ce sont les fromages qui sont là pour la
démonstration
là c'est une assiette qui ne servent
plus à rien et ici ce sont des biscuits
des petits beurres à l'envoyer ou sur
marveaux sur une table on peut voyez
comme ceux ci à la main les petits
beurres et bien à l'aide d'un rouleau de
pâtisseries avant on peut tous nous à
pâtisserie en rouleau à pâtisserie
parce que deux bâtisses et un sens pas
ça a lancé celui dont je serre les
choses ça va déménager pour lorsque le
mari rentre en retard la nuit alors ça
s'appelle comment celui-là l'oeil sur
une vocation spéciale c'est quand même
le rouge c'est un ballon non pas qu'il
ait fait un autre genre de
polar des quotas bon alors évidemment ça
prend beaucoup de temps bouteille cce
bouteille bien sûr
il vaut mieux toute façon on est en fait
non rêvant de toute façon vous voulez
bien aussi et vous allez voir que ça et
en nous faisant passer pour rappel
exactement ce que vous avez mis dans
votre cancer oui bien sûr parce qu'il
nous reste les amis du bonbon mais il
faut d'abord que j'allais chercher moi
côté geof à se voir comment vous faire
avoir des parts fini parce que j'en ai
tout de même qui s'en suit bien sûr ça
n'empêche pas de rappeler ce qu'on a mis
d'accord non non pas du tout maintenant
vous voulez mais bien sûr nous allons
rappeler qu'il faut 200 grammes c'est ce
que vous venez de faire la 200 g de
petits beurres que l'on écrase de la
manière que l'on préfet
on met une cuillerée à soupe de sucre et
puis 100 g de beurre et une pincée de
sel on mélange bien tout ça hein c'est
bien ça c'est tout à fait ça et puis
pour la galerie alors on mélange bien
bien bien jusqu'à ce que ce soit
homogène ensuite pour la garniture on a
pris trois cuillères à soupe de sucre
300 g de fromage blanc d'un genre de
fromage blanc que vraiment vous a
indiqué il ya quelques instants les deux
que vous j'ai tendu a vraiment qu'il a
mis dedans intégralement un 102e des
entier une cuillère à soupe de vanille
un tube de vanille 1 demi-citron de la
taille que vous souhaitez
et puis après nous allons passer aux
glaçages noter si vous voulez qu'il va
vous falloir une cuillère à soupe de
sucre 2 cuillères à soupe de crème et
une demi cuillère à café de vanille mais
là nous allons rester ici oui je vais me
livrer à la préparation du glaçage alors
j'avais eu une cuillère à soupe de sucre
dans un petit bol et d'atterrir sous peu
je veux ajouter une cuillère à soupe de
crème
et c'est fini
mélange du tout
bien objet viendront multitude bien
revenu et plus à loperhet le glaçage
tout de suite voilà
sur la tarte que vous avez terminé
lorsque nous avons commencé l'émission
vous présentez
vous voyez elle encouragerait les fruits
au liquid vous allez voir d'ailleurs qui
ne sont pas bons mais normalement je
devrais la laisser reposer 6 insiste
comme ceux-ci 5 à 6 minutes avant de
mettre les garçons je vais me remettre
au four mais là encore je me suis aperçu
que ces cinq ou six minutes et us en
réalité sans grand intérêt alors voyez
vous je mets le glaçage dessus avait mis
une cuillère à soupe de sucre et de
cuillères à soupe de crème n'ont jamais
fait une place à une cuillère à soupe de
sucre et une cuillère à soupe ah bon
vous avez 8,2 sur la recette avant que
je me suis trompé parce que je me suis
trompé dans la recette c'est là que j'ai
raison maillot quand il regarde les
essais en une seule à regarder elle est
largement insuffisante elle déborde
maintenant s'il fait bien modifier c'est
bien une seule qu'il resterait une seule
priorité pour cette heureuse cela alors
je le remets au four quelques secondes
par contre j'ai pas 1000 1
je n'ai pas de bonny dans le 6 janvier
dans la seconde à une demi cuillère à
café ah oui raymond ça j'y tiens bon
alors là c'est dans leurs discours sur
l'europe ont été brûlées vitrines
approcher une fois demi cuillère à café
voilà maintenant deux tartes fini alors
qu il était sorti de son monde et que
l'on voit coupée au pouce il vient
couper celle ci est celle ci que j'en
avais des moulins c'est le sport evo
connard je me bousculent pas alors j'en
enlève la première partie du cercle
si je veux je peux laisser comme ceci
est bon puisque de toute façon ça va
faire une protection en dessous et je
vais pouvoir la coupe est à vous allez
voir dans les coupes et akoupé vous
allez pouvoir goûter mais dites moi
sachant combien de personnes 5 1 moi je
pense que c'est pour quatre personnes je
pense que c'est pour quatre personnes
effectivement je sais c'est copieux
enfin c'est bien surtout qu'est ce qui
est à l'intérieur doit être sèche et oui
ma faim vous allez voir
alors il est recommandé de manger ce
plat extrêmement fins chaud froid au
contraire il faut qu'il fasse un petit
séjour dans le réfrigérateur avalant
couper les deux qui ont été faites ça ce
moment différent c'est à dire j'en ai
fait une ce matin que tu es un premier
nom dans le monde je vais dire un jour
peut-être pas le genre n'ont pas tout à
fait dans notre façon ok ce qui se passe
il n'y a pas deux comme je fais tout de
même
oui bonjour vieux parce que je dois
manger quelques minutes alors je fais un
tout petit peu plus vite qu'ils ne sera
nécessaire
peut-être alors voyez vous c'est très à
la première excellent
montre à la caméra si on peut le voir je
ne sais pas et voilà la seconde n'est ce
pas
on nous annonce les données de mettre
ici bien enlevé attendait voilà ce que
je pourrais faire si
c'est comme ceci pour que ça se voit
soit je pourrais lemaitre au 2e mais moi
je vais voir celle qui va sortir du faux
alors celle qui va sortir du four je
voudrais je vais me faire de la place
pour pouvoir la présenter cas
mais ce que vous m ainsi à contribution
ne vous moquez pas voilà et voilà
ceci va pouvoir aller ici et c'est la
quête au four
les terminer
l'émission
d'ailleurs vous avez quand même la
minute
nécessaire lutte de vérité comme la
corrida je ne sais pas vraiment quand
même il aurait peut-être fallu qu'elle
reste encore hier ils ne tiennent pas du
tout à la cale aux colorations il est il
absolument pas la colonne chasser
jusqu'au tes fidèles bien côté oui parce
que voyez-vous l'expérience m'a appris
que si je ne voulais pas une coloration
ton violente à la télé il fallait être
très modeste tu es toujours dessous mais
les cuites et les cuisses alors c'est
indiscutable voyez vous tenez je vais la
prendre avec une cuillère et au
avec la cuillère à pot elle est
parfaitement il fallait qu'elle
refroidisse il faut qu'elle refroidisse
pour qu'elle devienne qu'elle devienne
normal
côté rennais alors 15 minutes de cuisson
à feu moyen 5 minutes hors du four on a
pour la laisser refroidir un peu le
glaçage cinq minutes à nouveau c'est à
dire 20 minutes de cuisson en tout cas
cv voilà les voilà laisser refroidir et
même m
c'est exact je suis obligé de
reconnaître que c'est dit et ce côté
extrêmement friands de la pâte est très
amusant et voilà qu'après une heure
recettes américaines on aura tout vu un
tout petit j'étais plutôt hostile a
priori n'avait la prochaine fois ce sera
une recette deux fois france il vient
mais retirée bon nos téléspectateurs
sont probablement atteint leur disons
bien sûr comme d'habitude il peut vous
mais vraiment bonsoir et bon appétit et
l'afrique
[Musique]